They,
apple acts like it cares about privacy,
which maybe it doesn't turn certain over things to the FBI.
I don't know exactly what,
but we don't know what the apple phones are doing.
Right.
Apple is all locked down,
closed source.
And additionally I,
there was a creepy speech that Tim Cook just just gave creepy.
Did you see it?
No.
Let's listen to it.
Yeah.
Let's listen to [inaudible] music with Adl speech.
Do you have any spooky music you could play in the background while he's doing
this speech?
One thing we might get in trouble for that.
So again,
it's good intentions.
Like people who want less hate speech,
we all want less h beach was,
we want people to get along better.
Yeah.
Right.
But this idea that,
I don't want to give too much away,
but you know,
he's acting as if they are going to be the moral authority about the types of
content that can exist on the APP store.
Yeah.
So I just don't know how that's scalable.
What does that mean?
Like let's hear what you said.
I was just hoping this is the right one.
Is it?
It says a CEO,
Tim Cook banning hate division is the right thing to do.
12 three 2018 is that it?
December.
That's it.
Okay.
Let's hear it.
Hello,
Tim.
Volume please.
Our devices connected
did to the humanity that makes us us.
We do that in many ways.
What are the most important is how we honor a teaching that can be found in
Judaism,
but it's shared across all faiths and traditions.
It's a lesson that was carried forward by the late Elie was make his memory be a
blessing.
It's a lesson put into practice by America's Muslim community who raised
thousands for the victims of the tree of life killings,
Lowe,
Tom Mode.
I'll dom Rebecca,
do not be indifferent to the bloodshed of your fellow man.
Do not be indifferent.
Yeah.
This mandate moves us to speak up for immigrants and for,
for those who seek opportunity in the United States,
we do it not only because they're individual dignity,
creativity and ingenuity have the power to make this country and even better
place,
but because our own humanity commands us to welcome those who knew need welcome.
It moves us to speak up for the Lgbtq community for those whose differences can
make them a target for violence and scorn.
We do so.
Not only because these unique and uncommon perspectives can open our eyes to new
ways of thinking,
but because their own dignity moves us to see the dignity and others.
Perhaps most importantly,
it drives us not to be bystanders.
Bystanders,
as hate tries to make its headquarters in the digital world
at apple,
we believe that technology needs to have a clear point of view on this
challenge.
There is no time to get tied up in knots.
That's why we only have one message for those who seek to push hate division and
violence.
You have no place on our platforms.
[inaudible]
you have no home here from the earliest days of Itunes to apple music today.
We have always prohibited music with a message of white supremacy.
Hold on.
Sorry.
Um,
what,
what do you think there's signaling here?
Like are they signaling that they're about to start censoring things?
Like what do you,
what do use any,
are they already,
are they okay?
I agree with you.
Shit.
You probably shouldn't put white supremacy music on,
but there's a lot of like really violent stuff that you can get on iTunes.
Right?
I mean if you go back to the old Nwa albums,
there's some that's available,
right?
Sure.
I guess I would,
I'm assuming.
Yeah,
I saw that.
It is for sure.
But yeah,
like straight Outta Compton,
uh,
some violence shit.
And then how about the films that they have?
How about the films that you can get on the iTunes store?
There is a lot of very,
very,
very violent films,
like extremely violent.
There's a lot of films that like,
is it that they're making the distinction between something that's fiction that
although it may be disturbing,
you understand that this is a movie and this is something someone wrote versus
someone art versus,
yeah.
Versus someone with commentary,
their commentaries here.
And then here's the other thing.
Well he was saying hate and division,
they won't promote division,
but that's a weird one.
Yeah.
That means like what does that mean?
People who disagree with you?
Yeah,
what does division has good intentions.
You can sort of feel it.
Yeah,
that's the problem with this,
right,
that it's,
he's not allowing the conversation to take place.
So this is in direct conflict with the Daryl Davis is with confronting these
issues.
Right?
So w we can kill it,
but I think,
uh,
when,
when he's saying you have no place on our platform,
they probably feel like you can go somewhere else.
He's building a wall.
Yeah.
I mean,
but this is what I'm saying.
Like everybody kind of feels like you can go somewhere else.
That's what happens though.
And that's how things get more radicalized and everybody goes down.
So I don't know,
you know,
look,
the conversation needs to take place.
People on the left,
he's acting like he's speaking for all Lgbtq people.
He's not,
there's lots of people on the left and Lgbtq people aren't always on the left
and not all of them want that.
Well,
not only that,
there's division in LBGT and cue,
like there's a,
there's a big issue right now with Martina Navratilova that was going on about
her discussing the reality of Trans Women competing against biological women and
that she opposes it and she thinks it is.
There's some fundamental advantages,
which is leading to a lot of weight lifting world records being broken by Trans
Women.
And she's like,
this is fucking preposterous.
Including Trans Women with penises and now they're attacking her for being trans
phobic.
So there's not even a United need knighted opinion in the Lbgtq community for
sure.
And that's why that uh,
Megan Murphy I think,
yes.
The,
I go to this restaurant in Bridgeport,
Connecticut called blood root,
which is like sort of an old school feminist like vegetarian Vegan spot and in
Bridgeport.
In Bridgeport,
yeah.
Bridgeport's con no,
no offense.
I know it's kind of a dump.
Wild place.
Yeah.
We would have a gathering in the vibe of music festivals.
I helped organize,
I used to stand up in Bridgeport.
Please call the joker's wild.
It was a comedy club.
So,
so the OAA beat a guy with a shoe there,
beat a guy in the face with a shoe,
pull the shoe off and intervene.
I was 24 I know what the fuck was going on.
So anyway though,
that restaurant that you know,
they get called,
um,
what is it?
Turf.
Uh,
turf.
Yeah.
Trans exclusionary radical feminists.
And so again,
you know,
they're the old school ones and they're saying,
look,
you know,
we're not against your,
your battle right now.
We're not against trans.
Right.
It's obvious who would be against trans.
Yeah.
But they're just saying that's not our thing.
So again,
there's diversity and they're trying to clump everyone together and the whole
intersectional world.
And I look,
people want to band together.
This oppress groups want to band together.
They should.
Yeah.
But like,
it's not that simple.
Well,
there's always going to be differing opinions and especially when you have
something like,
you know,
Trans Women competing against biological women and you know,
you have someone like Martina Navratilova that made her,
her life's work and her career competing as a biological woman.
Um,
she's going to have some opposition to that.
And then the idea that everyone's supposed to be lumped in together with some
mandate that no one has really openly discussed and you're supposed to agree and
it fluctuates and moves like the tide,
you know,
like what is and isn't moves like the tide.
It changes.
It's like this court of public opinion.
It's,
it's constantly rendering new verdicts and you have to keep up and catch up.
Things that were acceptable just a few years ago are totally unacceptable.
I mean,
comedy is,
is the key area too.
Yeah.
That is not what's happening on social media now.
Not Sustainable for comedy because it's fine.
Oh really?
Yeah,
it is.
It is.
How?
Because it creates outrage and then comedy,
it relieves that,
that pressure,
like,
believe me,
there's a lot of blow back and believe me,
there's a lot of debate and discussion,
but also,
believe me,
when someone does do some politically incorrect,
really good standup people go fucking bonkers.
They love it.
It's going,
it's like one of the best times ever right now to do stand up people go fucking
ape.
Yeah,
no,
it's incredible material.
But I'm just saying for you know,
comics that are running into issues with getting banned or whatnot.
I mean,
well,
who's running the issues with getting banned?
I mean,
I think,
you know,
one oh one.
Yeah.
Oh.
And has some issues.
Yeah.
Um,
and you know,
you can make some arguments at Owens not doing so well right now.
Um,
but he's also developing his following because of the fact there's people that
don't agree with him being banned.
He's,
he's a very specific example.
Um,
other people that are being banned.
Do you know of other who,
what other standup comedian you've done a bunch of comics on?
Maybe they haven't been fully been from social media,
but they've had their performances,
uh,
shutdown.
Who's that one guy who was at oh no mesh,
no mesh hotel.
But that was at a college see you the same.
It's the same thing.
Yes.
But universities have been bad for that for a long time.
Uh,
they're the most sensitive of all audiences and they're the ones who are the
most,
uh,
they believe the most,
that they're going to change the world and that their ideals are,
their ideals are rock solid and they have to push back against anything that
opposes them.
Ari was temporarily banned.
That was an accident.
Yeah.
The Ra thing was he was joking around and they thought he was making legitimate
death threat could,
that could happen just jacking around with a good friend of ours,
the,
the algorithms or are in the moderators are just not right.
We can't just be having this happen all the time and then they just keep saying,
oh,
sorry.
Yeah,
There has to be a new approach completely.
It can't just be,
oh,
let them back on and,
and just keep doing what they're doing.
Like we need to completely reapproach how moderation is happening.
The whole policies situation,
that transparency situation,
it's not just a matter of
going to the overlords and saying,
can I,
can I please come back?
Right.
It's,
that's not that,
that's not suitable for the communication structure of the planet earth.
Well,
I think what's not suitable is that commerce should not dictate how human beings
are allowed to openly communicate with each other.
And one of the things that Jack said that's kind of contrary to his company's
actions was that he believes that the ability to communicate as a fundamental
right,
like the ability to get electricity.
Like if you're in the KKK,
you could still order electricity,
you know?
So should you be able to just distribute information?
If people say no,
then you have to say,
okay,
well who's to decide what can and cannot be distributed?
And then who's to decide if they can go somewhere else.
And then what happens if you tell a person they can't go anywhere?
Done things get really weird.